hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i'm
gonna hit you in the face with butts
butts
butts there are so many butts look how
happy biski is
now look at how happy hiskey is it's
been a really long week but we've heard
enough about magical appendages so let's
get behind some more magic in episode 68
and 60 nice
we continued to use some great game
mechanics to get through with a bunch of
throwaway characters whose names i only
learned because one of them had
gravity-denying breasticles knowing
the abilities of the one opponent i know
for a fact is a real person outside of
the game and knowing that we have a
hunter hunter
high q crossover it's kind of exciting
because we know there's a team game
coming up and well well well
look who it is my favorite naked swingy
boy who
for one frame despite having a purple
glistening
wet shwing there for everyone to see was
actually as smooth as a kendall he
soaked a swing too long and it melted
away
which apparently didn't stop them from
being concerned with the schwing
in fact they became more concerned with
it as it rose to the occasion as it were
and he obviously didn't care and
actually hang on let's go
back for a second because i can't
remember what his name is but we now
have two contenders for sexiest butt on
hunter hunter
and no we're not talking about kilwan
gone we're talking about that other guy
whose booty we started on
what is going on with tagashi dude you
need to calm right down
it's maybe one of the times i really
don't actually want to see
those patterns because despite the other
guy just outright calling hisoka a perv
we still had a lot of but this episode
and i
now don't like that we know where
tagashi's head
was at because he always does this don't
tell me when you're thinking about booty
always so let's move on from booty and
talk about these here pirates
they weren't and won't be particularly
dangerous
i'm kind of excited by the idea of the
groundhog day type situation for the
non-player character when they return
how well does the game learn does it
learn at all will kiwa have to do
something different will gon get to
punch him instead there's no way hisoka
is leaving them without seeing what they
can do it was a really interesting issue
that came up with that pirate actually
between gone
actually showing some empathy to someone
who was weak but still being killed
which
i understand the game showing
consequences to actions but i find it
really fascinating that if the pirates
aren't real people for the characters to
actively decide that being set on fire
and immolated
which i imagine is what would have
happened is appropriate and
acceptable the reason i find this
interesting is that it tells us how
close gone and killer are to end game
material
if tagashi is using concepts that fit
there's a point in well-balanced games
ones that aren't dark souls which is
brutal from the start where the big bad
isn't going to let you go if you mess up
the big battle makes sure you can't get
in their way again the easiest way to do
that is just to kill the opponent
yes it's harsh but in a world where the
conceit is everything is ultimately a
game we need to be harsh
especially since the people playing the
game are supposed to be some of the most
dangerous individuals on the planet
so we went from gone caring about that
to kilwa who then set the dude's head on
fire
i mean there's still such good balances
for each other there's a lot of wisdom
on kilauea's end about learning not to
show more power than he needs to for a
situation but gone's not gonna listen to
that because he's gone
which is great because we immediately
stepped into the greed olympics and the
two boys showed us that they had learned
their lessons well
nothing that happened in the ring was
particularly dangerous thinking about it
and
looking it up because i never played
volleyball in school there are only
usually six people on a volleyball team
but sexy butt guy says there are eight
challenges what's going to happen to the
final two
let's ignore that for a bit volleyball
guy will probably make it an eight on
eight if he's feeling kind
something that i really enjoyed about
this episode were the variety of
artistic styles we hit it was
basically a sitcom of styles that took
us from the beginning with the normal
fighting
in a pirate situation through the sexy
butt's reveal
through gone and gila arguing and
bisky's cutesy look and hot eyes
oh and his keys his guinness overall
the episode was this comedic jump from
style to style and i imagine if i were
to check the manga it would probably be
much the same
and i appreciate that i appreciate the
chibi look of the end of the episode
with those intros to things i appreciate
rat killah
i don't care how many times you say he's
a cat he's a rat so that i appreciate
all the little nods to other genres that
turn up in this one and the fact that
this show itself
jumps from genre to genre depending on
where we are in the arc
i appreciate that tagashi brings
everything he is and has learned over
the years to the style of the artwork he
creates
and then into how to tell the kind of
stories he wants to tell
fire-breathing kids wouldn't have fit in
karapika's arc everything there was dark
and gloomy because it was kurapika's ark
everything here is gone and kilwa and
the childishness of them so it makes
sense that it would be reflected in the
actual art style it's freeing and
something that is
actually quite unique for the show in
fact there had been so many different
styles of the episode that by the time
we saw hisoka and his specially placed
tree brunch i was somewhat expecting
we'd have a brief scene of his hair
going from wet to floppy
to poofing out into hisoka style kind of
like how beyonce did it in that movie
back in yeah baby
yeah i can't remember but of course we
can't go there because that doesn't
fully fit hiskey's style
and what does women randomly falling in
his path that he completely ignores and
his
search for not boredom i love that once
he was told hisoka was lying kilwa acted
as though the idea had been his from the
start in a very
kilwa way sure he probably knew hisoka
was lying who wouldn't it's hisoka
the point is that he took that
information ran with it and thought it
through he had a good outcome too but
they weren't watching him with
oh i'm gonna say if i'm correct
please give me a thumbs up now there's
only so long this is going to work
anyway and i'm excited to see what does
happen so let's move on to episode 60
nice
nine of us have to win ah so the tables
have turned
says gets to get i know how to spell
your name because i had to keep copying
it down
from crunchyroll prove you're good
enough to join our crew and instantly
fail with
a jump then smacked in the back with a
dodgeball well done old man who's
actively intensely powerful and much
faster than i am
maybe you'll be as good as these two
young teens eventually we doubt it
though the closest you'll get will be
your white eyebrows that only get
more awkward the more frustrated you
look the frustration didn't last though
because we were back into the
magical world of card collecting once
more except this time our protags care
which is a nice change i guess the
puzzle pieces are starting to be nudged
together at this point which
finally and i'm glad because giving us
more context clues about how close the
bad guys are getting to finishing the
game is the perfect nudge to beat this
here game master so it sounds like
tagashi's been playing some tabletop now
the thing is if they beat the
game mustard that's how they say it
dodge ball dude and they will ultimately
i guess
oh dodgeball not volleyball i mean look
anyway if they beat the game master
slash
dodgeball dude and they will oh sexy
butt guy this is this is him
sexy butt and they will ultimately i
guess because gone's been hit in the
head and he cares now because when he
gets hit in the head suddenly he cares
about things and he wants to
hurt people more because he got hit in
the head i'm starting to wonder if
getting hit in the head is
actually the reason why he decides that
he's going to defeat people
concussion can do a lot anyway when they
beat the game master
they have to be able to hold the card
they get and they might not be able to
do that without killing bomber guy
i'm very much at this point waiting for
when hisoka is going to double cross
them who's the person he's looking for
is it sexy but game master or is it
going to
be the bomber and how would he get what
he wants to get out of them
is there an item in the game that allows
him to deal with crollo's nan
because we can't forget that's the thing
hisoka hates boredom over everything
else
i'd love to do a deep dive into his mind
actually maybe one day
i feel like that's his biggest fear
running out of people to
fight or things to keep himself active
it's why he's willing to pair up with
people and do whatever he can to help
them improve so that he can beat back
the boredom by beating off
their abilities he has an urge to grow
just like gone except his urges and his
growth is sexual whilst gonz
is instinctive maybe i'm still not sure
what they are maybe just cheer fun maybe
that's his future to
find out that actually he gets sexual
enjoyment from seeing people reach their
potential
that seems like something tagashi would
do either way we have a gun who's been
smacked down
a lot of really generic oh my god look
at them they're so freaking generic guys
who are
all very normal and they skip the
pirates who hey
let's note that i was totally right the
pirates are real people who live in real
places it's
interesting that the concept of taboo is
a thing have they come across other
characters who they thought were not
real people who actually were and does
that mean kilwa set a real dude
i remember his name because i'm sorry
got his head set on fire why didn't they
have to do the task
twice or did they do the task twice and
that's why
decided not to do it anymore so he went
from burning to exploding but only one
of those killed him
sometimes tagashi switches perspective
on characters for reasons i don't fully
understand
yes says yes seguras is
supposed to marvel at how far they've
come but why do we need him to
understand
that like why do we need to understand
his view on understanding that
why do we need to know that he knows
that other people
know it felt if i'm honest like filler
that would have been just as easily
served by the widened eyes and
frustration of the opening of the
episode before they went right in and
decided to actually engage i
liked having the idea of nen enhancing
symbols teased at us that's the kind of
subtle addition i appreciate but overall
his desire to go back and train seems a
little out of place and unnecessary
given he has a broken back and a sitting
court side in a game he's unlikely to
leave
particularly alive so this dodgeball
game i mean i was totally wrong in the
last episode and i did get distracted by
butts it wasn't volleyball it was
dodgeball and i feel like despite all
the rules that made gone in my head
steam which
in itself is odd and weird and unfair
because i've played and refereed
extensive amounts of good dodgeball in
my time
i feel like he's just making up rules as
they go along to help sexy butt win
which seems like an unnecessary
advantage given his current ability
i mean i suppose he was the one who made
the referee
and one of the developers of the game so
it makes sense he would find a way to up
the difficulty if necessary
knowing jing is a fantastic addition
because now gone has his
push from dad sexy butt has his interest
peaked
and everyone else is standing courtside
thinking uh
or if it's hisoka because gone is gone
he's going to catch that ball eventually
but when
i don't know but i hope it's next
episode because that's it from me
if you enjoyed this ramble about sexy
butts and schwings into sport please
clicky click here
there and everywhere check out the
discord have a great day and i'll see
you
next time